thank you for the extraordinary
opportunity
now
sashay
away
thank you to my sister i love you guys
i love you
i feel good this morning like i have
time to process everything and like i
feel proud of what i did i don't regret
anything i had the time of my life oh
the ocean is rising
and she is so salty
i'm so proud to have been able to be
part of that and i've watched drag race
so many years like 15 years and like to
be able to welcome that runway for the
first time i was like oh my god like i
made it
you did make it so my biggest question
for you today osean is
did you eat cheeseburgers
so now i get to go home and eat some
cheeseburgers
you know that's funny because when i got
eliminated the one of the producers like
put me in a little place that you know
to to to process my feeling and
everything and when i entered that place
there was like three uh mcdonald bags
there was putin burgers everything i'd
wish for so i oh yeah i'm feeling good
listen i'm a bit confused because you
were cast on canada's drag race season
two and not canadian idol
um oh my god
[Music]
did you expect that you would have to
sing live yeah i was like really august
because you know uh i think they did
that only one year i think i think it
wasn't season six and like in like 15
seasons and everything so i was like
there's no chance that's gonna happen to
me i didn't even think about it so
like when it happened i was like already
when they said you have to sing live i
knew that i was indeed uh
you know deep something
i think that what happened is that i
lost my focus completely so it took me
out of the number inner saboteur i want
to get a little tea from you so if you
were not the person to go home this week
who do you think should have went home
instead of you
that question
um i would say
um
maybe i would maybe eve because our
things were all falling off on stage and
the reveal didn't go as planned also the
singing was horrible but i'm not the one
to tell i'm not the one to talk because
mine is too so you know but uh yeah
i expected her to be in the battle more
than isis because i don't think isis was
that
i don't think that isis was that bad she
struggled a bit but you know
i i i don't know i i felt i was sure
that it was about to be
oh hey there if you want more lgbtq news
and exclusive interviews click subscribe
or watch these videos